I wanna lose control so I'm ready to
roll
[Music]
feels like I've been walking on ice
wanna let everything go and feel alright
in the drums and our bodies I know we
live in money time we gonna have a good
time
a dozen hands up to the sky we gonna
toast
I wanna I wanna lose I'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy Tuesday I want to say Wow only
Tuesday there we're just chugging along
it is truly the first time that Jackie
and I have been in this studio alone in
like six months
snitch took the day off she is not
feeling well Mitch is not on Tuesday not
on the Cho's so we are here by ourselves
like I hope we can you know do the show
without her she's such an integral part
she really has got to get our own
coffees this morning shudder I actually
don't drink coffee to growth and I just
I didn't realize how much the presence
of this niche really impacts the show by
the way I totally agree because Snitch
always get to your pros first I usually
get here second so I got here second but
I was first and I had literally no one
to talk to
your biggest nightmare no peeing alone I
know hello no one to talk to I know no
one to just not even talk to you just
listen to me we have to talk at know
totally Cissna ch
if you're watching somewhere which you
should because it's still your job we
miss you and your presence is keenly
felt it is and so is your accent we're
looking we're looking forward to your
return to the Cho's but until then we
got we got it you know we will hold down
the fort just like we used to in the
good old days
yeah just like we used to feels weird it
does that's what counselors do though
yeah they make people feel comfortable
they keep the bunks safe and that's and
that's what they're doing so it's really
sad that she's sick like she's such a
sad sick person
she was I was talking about tonight I
was talking to her last night about her
being sick and she was like crying about
the sickness and it's just really sad
she's pathetic like she's so helpless
yeah justice for Mara so sad that she
was sick but then I was happy because I
got my headshots back oh my god that was
so funny I saw your Instagram story and
they listened without sound first and
they got someone photoshopped this
picture beyond my check he would never
take a picture like that but I did how
okay so when Zach and I were on vacation
we were at like a beach club for lunch
and they have photographers that go
around and like take pictures of groups
because then you'll want to buy the
picture true so there was a photographer
and he was taking a lot of pictures our
table and like the pictures were like
feeling cute he was taking all this
creative direction so like Zach's add
like Mike made a whole thing of it and
like procured the photos afterwards I
never thought about them again or heard
from them but Zach came home last night
the printed photos and like when we took
the pictures they were a couple shots
like in the pictures of him like you can
see my hands on his shoulders like he's
separated you in every job and act like
there's only one photo of us together
and it's like so blurry it's the
strangest thing ever except I did have a
head shot I'm gonna be in a hallmark
movie like I mean now that you have an
official headshot you have to start
making the rounds go to auditions no I
have vaguely this newfound ambition for
being in a hallmark movie like I feel
like I did about two years ago and then
you know like priority priorities we're
like regenerate life happens life
happens um but now like this is really
what I want to do like I might even take
an acting class so that if the day comes
I am prepared actually that I did take
an acting class I know right before my
and you said it helped and you know what
it does because you want to know why
what's hard about acting that I feel
like a lot of people like diminish is
when you get a script and you're just
reading it it's super hard to understand
the context of what's going on and like
when someone says how are you doing like
they might be being sarcastic and like
you don't know that so having an acting
coach is really helpful in helping
understand like the context of the scene
and like what you're supposed to be
feeling so I went to an acting coach it
was incredibly awkward like she
literally sat in front of me like made
me redo the scene 500 times in front of
her and I felt so much shame like I
wanted to die shameful I know and it's
almost like it's obviously more
prestigious to have like a one-on-one
acting coach but it might be a little
less awkward to be in like a full class
maybe I don't know I saw me she burnt
you can work with an acting coach on the
hills and she really turned her around
let me know if you want my girl she
lives in Tribeca which was like that
idea apart so not a great endorsement
did I tell the story on the toast about
the episode of SVU yeah I think we're
watching a nameís episode okay and forth
and I'm firmly in believe now I didn't
get the world not because I wasn't
talented enough because I just think
they were looking for like a really sad
person and like I just can't emulate
that kind of sadness because I'm
fabulous and from New York and like they
wanted this girl to be like like tragic
from Pensacola you know yeah but I don't
know I feel like in another life you
were he was in Pensacola
no I just feel like the show was about
an Instagram star and the fact that they
didn't want me to play the Instagram
star who got to make out with Steve
Howey from Reba the daughter's boyfriend
I know I just saw the episode and I was
like I mean I was never even up for the
girl who was the interim
like I don't know why I am and insurance
are but if I was I would have gotten to
make out with Steve Howey damn that's
the missed opportunity I know but I was
never even like giving that opportunity
so yes so I don't know if your acting
coach like is really comes highly
recommended considering you're not of
working in her defense I literally met
with her the day of the audition I got
like absolutely no like time from my
agents and they were just like just do
your best and I was like okay yeah your
best was not good enough no but if you
do go to an acting class I will 100% go
with you okay no that will make me more
merits like I don't care to be like
weird and freaky like in front of people
I don't know but like when you're there
like you'll just make me laugh
no but I'm I'm serious like I want to be
on SVU I don't actually I don't know
what I want to be on more SVA we're Blue
Bloods I think I'll have a better time
on set of Blue Bloods but I think for my
career I think I should be honest for
you yeah because that's like a great
starting point for you and they think a
great starting point for me is like a
lead in a hallmark film I mean that's
ambitious but like toasters were sending
me like the greatest thought out it's
great I wonder if you can increase your
chances of getting on the homework
Network if you come with your own script
and it's actually like a good movie make
it a full package yeah like you like you
don't need to hire writers yeah because
I have it all here for you yeah that
would be really no but they like they're
right I think they like their in-house
writers but I think it definitely helps
to like I'm coming with an audience
we're ready to go I think once you go in
the podcast like that will be the
springboard you think so yeah I don't
know I think I should like ask our
agents like get mean I think you should
100% like maybe for a next Christmas
season I could be in Hallmark the film
movies in like a month you could still
get in this season you know like a
January late Christmas or like Christmas
at Graceland I would love that I think I
think you should work on it yeah I think
it's time to like start pursuing some
more dreams you know hi Jackie I totally
agree we've achieved like so many of our
like short-term and longer your goals
and now it's like what what are my real
goals and like this and Dancing with the
Stars like are really hallmark movie is
my dream yeah and I think setting goals
for yourself I've said this before is so
important because you never know like if
you're really progressing in your life
if you're not setting in accomplishing
goals so let's set our goals right now
okay you want to I want to bless you
let's you realistic okay I want to be
in a hallmark movie someway somehow and
like no I don't want to be an extra
actually but like it's the best I can do
goal accomplished my goal is just to be
like one a person in an episode of SVU
like one who's about the case like I
won't carry over into the storyline up
next you'll be like the girl's friend
who like you know you're giving evidence
that's like but then it turns are
pertinent to the situation then it turns
out like me and her boyfriend were
actually good you know right cuz he just
covers it
yeah and he was played by John Mayer
loved it loved it
yeah what else I didn't want to paradise
last night because we have been loving
saving it all for one night so I don't
have to deal with their lame
cliffhangers yeah no I I didn't watching
it was actually the first time this
season I didn't watch live and I thought
I would be having more fun well based on
like Instagram and tweets but I didn't
really see much
so just play court since like goodbye
posts oh my god he's acting like he was
I can't like he's so divided okay enough
so his strategy for powder is his social
media strategy was um I'm gonna post
something like when the [ __ ] hits the
fan I'm gonna throw a really nice girl
under the bus somewhere I'm sorry I'm
looking at myself in this headband and I
look like I'm more like you know there's
something about this headband I look
amazing in there like looking you look
cute put it back on or sure yeah okay
I'm feeling it's like but don't do the
ear thing I'm feeling like look you know
but your hair behind your ears okay no
no like that okay I like tuck and then
headband yes yes I think that might be
it alright and we have that piece of
hair to like the front this piece yes
yes okay we'll say it's just watch out
for your mic okay so he's social media
strategy yeah should hit the fan
he threw a very nice girl under the bus
in order to protect his name then
decided to go silent until I'm assuming
he went home last night and posted about
his time in paradise like I can't think
of a worse strategy if I tried like I
did not capitalize on his time on TV now
with himself look even guilty or and
sadder than he did to begin with like
had absolutely no redeeming moment in
paradise like justice for Caitlyn I'll
say it again and then his social media
strategy keeps us keeps reminding us of
the thing that happened what you did
like because this was a month ago that's
like six months ago in paradise like we
are so on to bigger and better things
like no one gives a [ __ ] about you Blake
or the Caitlyn drama or any of the drama
so like the fact that you went radio
silent on Instagram and now we're
putting together like a speech about
your traumatic time on paradise totally
mining us of the thing you did is
releasing
sex twitch is evil right but like I had
forgotten about that but you keep
reminding me right like if he just moved
on and like puts itself is at him and
his dog 100% I'd be like what he does
silly silliness ya know so that was
that's what not to do yeah but I look
forward to watching tonight and then
recapping on the snatchler tomorrow if
you have not listened to this match
alert it is the premiere bachelor
podcast I feel like we we get really
like sociological about what goes on on
that be it's definitely a below the
surface level kind of show yeah like
human behaviors analyze it's not just
surface lyrics what I was thinking oh my
god I think the service lyrics is my
favorite like inside joke for our family
have we said it on the show I think we
have I know but you know maybe there's a
new person watching okay so also by the
way we recorded an episode of off the
vine with Kaitlyn Bristowe yesterday and
it was really funny I wonder when it's
gonna come out I feel like maybe not for
a while but I look forward to when it
does also Monsieur shall to friend of
the toast
Lauren Everts who is pregnant like I was
shook I've never been like shocked by
someone's pregnancy like I usually like
can tell like they're not drinking or
they're like wearing big sweatshirts she
hit it perfectly I'll tell you why you
were so shocked it's because the
toasters hadn't figured it out before
yes there hasn't been a pregnancy
announcement of late where it wasn't in
the toasters before either someone like
put the pieces together or know someone
who knows someone swimmin I'm never
actually shocked when the news comes out
but she hid it from everyone especially
the toasters and that's why we were
truly shocked and then she also had like
the most epic announcement with that
picture of which was inspired by the
fake gentleman picture congratulations
I'm actually like hate when people get
pregnant and like then I had to follow
them in their content changes but like
I'm living for stating confidential like
her first photo from pregnant life
premium yeah no this bodes well for
primary contact yeah okay so is it time
it's time I think do you think yeah
switch isn't here to like say it's time
I know it's time each each time for the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and that's true
you know we'll least few facts on this
show so I'm telling you that it's
definitely true but it's it's important
that I preface the entire episode with
the fact that today's episode is brought
to you by Felix gray you may not realize
it but the average American blasts their
eyes with brightness on screens for over
11 hours a day we
he's gonna check our speech where am i
felix grace i met 12 and a half hours on
my screen time these days like it's why
dad I know that's so bad when you
consider how much our day revolves our
devices it doesn't seem so crazy the
fact is we can't eliminate exclude
extensive screen time from our lives but
you can't protect your eyes from it with
a pair of Felix grey blue light
filtering glasses available in both non
prescription and prescription so I
didn't know that like you didn't need to
have a prescription to get like the
special glasses for your eyes because
when I watch TV before better from
scrolling on my phone before bed I
usually get a migraine and it's torture
but wearing a pair of Felix gray glasses
can actually protect your eyes from the
harmful rays you know the UV blue light
all the drama no [ __ ] cuz you're at 12
hours the majority of Americans live
with tired dry eyes blurry vision or
headaches may cause by screens if this
sounds familiar Felix great glasses are
for you they filter out 90% of the
high-energy blue light and eliminate 99%
glare coming from your daily barrage of
screens
unlike other blue light glasses Felix
gray uses proprietary blue light
technology embedded into the lens as
opposed to cheap coating that can easily
chip or scratch over time their frames
are handcrafted by than the same quality
materials using high-end designer frames
like organic Italian acetate and German
engineered steel their glasses are
available in Nam description
prescription readers as well as kid
sizes I'm sorry
it was another falsely in the middle of
literally making money for carrying the
cash stop futzing with the cop ok I'm
sorry
it was another false Lynda don't go
another day looking at screens without
the help of some Felix gray go to Felix
grey glasses comm slash toast for free
shipping in 30 days of risk-free returns
or exchanges that's Fe Li X G RA Y
glasses comm fastest Chucky's listening
if you like the teacher the teacher AB
Felix gray glasses fel IX g ra y glasses
comm slash toast free shipping in 30
days of riskily returns or exchanges
that's Felix wear glasses comm slash
toast
Felix gray glasses comm slash toast love
it that's what happens in the snatchers
not here I got a false lid no one to
help me had to suffer through it myself
you're gonna be okay and well because I
fixed it look at that premium lid sister
DIY lid okay
first story a little Billy Bush news
he's back in the news he's getting back
to work
and this morning he's sitting down with
Gayle King that an intern in an
interview that's probably airing them
but here's a little teaser he says that
everyone at NBC knew about the Access
Hollywood tape the existence of the now
infamous Access Hollywood tape was
common knowledge at NBC according to
Billy Bush in a tease for Gayle Kings
sit-down interview with Bush for CBS he
says everyone at the peacock Network
knew about the vulgar recording and
assured him it wouldn't be a problem
you knew there was a tape King says in
the interview everybody did response
Bush the new host of a syndicated
entertainment show extra I didn't jokes
King oh well everybody at the network
knew I was comfortable it wasn't going
to be weaponized
but famously it was he went down and
apparently he's saying now that not only
wasn't used like as a present for the
presidential campaign but also Matt
Lauer wanted him out oh my god Matt
Lauer is so [ __ ] Cheney like I don't
know what he did to chairman Hall but I
know it was Evo and then like what he
did with to the ladies in his office
with that button under his desk good
button the button like um I can't even
stress enough how no one in the
corporate office setting like needs an
emergency lock button under their desk
no but I was just got a pin lock the
door I started Californication which is
the worst show I don't recommend it and
I didn't finish it but Charlie York's
husband harry goldenblatt is like a main
character in it and he's got a big
Hollywood agent and he has about another
desk and I was like before the Matt
Lauer that [ __ ] that means like people
in the industry like knew about it
yeah no it's definitely a thing and even
when we talked about it with Matt Lauer
like people were writing in like
explaining what that button might do
sometimes for like you know confidential
conversation it's like are you [ __ ]
kidding me like close the door
TV yeah it's so stupid um my question is
who actually did leak the the tape they
say a staffer at the Today Show's I
think they try and make it sound like a
low-level person who like just like
snuck the tapes off bro but I feel as
though it was definitely like a
coordinated like that things like that
don't just leave yeah well poor really
Bush because like he didn't really do
anything in the video he just like
listened it was being a loser
yeah and like his whole life was ruined
no and like he actually met Billy bug he
met Billy Bush and I also once was in a
cell cycle class with him
we met with Billy Bush and his publicist
and they were just like asking for our
opinion on like his situation and I
actually felt really badly for him he
was a super nice guy I did too and I
feel
and I've been using this example up
until now but he's finally going back to
work so hopefully things aren't gonna
turn around for him but I get a divorce
right is he oh yeah yeah he's just like
going through a rough time I feel like
he is one of the few people who has yet
to bounce back from a cancellation that
doesn't have to do with like uh you know
committing a crime and sexually
assaulting someone ya know I I feel
really like sad for him like I feel like
we're ready for him to get back to work
people felt like [ __ ] up all the time
and people have been forgiven for far
worse right so like I don't know if it
was maybe just like him not handling him
not ready to get back to work him not
needing to get back to work I don't know
what his situation is unless we not
forget he is a bush but it says he has a
new gig yaksha which is perfect I didn't
know that yeah you know he looks so much
like and I always confuse him when
George Bush no because they're cousins
no do you know that yes you know who you
reminds me so much of the actor in Devil
Wears Prada who's Andy's like French
boyfriend
oh the blonde I honestly forgot me for
most of my life I thought that they were
the same person he says that we see
Billy Bush on commercials for like
Access Hollywood or whatever and I was
like oh my god that guy from Devil Wears
Prada is like has such a bustling career
that's really not the worst call I've
ever heard at all and I really thought
they were the same person for so long
that's when I was younger I really could
not tell the difference between Sandra
Bullock and Julia Roberts yeah I mean
I've so many of those people and like
you know what it's fine
he really needs to know I don't I don't
mean to Julie you know I don't need to
know who Billy Bush versus her friend's
boyfriend is Chuck Boulais whatever is
it oh so he wasn't friends she was like
American he would they like [ __ ] in
France you know yeah yeah for sure and
he was one who told her about juggling
filet yes he gave her the T yeah the
French T the espresso anyways I'm happy
for really bullish like it's time but
like because I feel as though and I saw
a headline yesterday um when I was
looking for news stories where he was
like I'm never gonna talk about this
ever again and I just feel like he
always finds himself talking about it
and then I don't think never talking
about it again this is the way to go
either no I don't so you have to talk
about your cancellation like at least
once in order to move on I feel like you
should start a consulting company that
couldn't agree more Blake needs
come through the door light Reggie it's
like he hasn't been canceled but he's
had like some he's acting like he was
kids right so like I feel bigger small
cancellations like you guys should
haven't talked to us cuz like I really
feel as though we see all sides of it
and we've done a pretty good job Jackie
I think that's actually a brilliant move
that's literally what Billy Bush was
doing to us but we was before we were
cancelled right he was just like tapping
into a colonial showing us our future
yeah he was really like a foreshadowing
what was gonna happen yeah and we were
all high and mighty on that couch you
know really what you do well good times
anyways let's think about it you know
things if you ever get cancelled again
like that could be our next space our
next business yeah I like that idea a
lot
the can be closed Alton oh yeah
cancellation consultancy and then we
started a home hurt movie okay the
cancellation consultancy okay next story
a little more justice news is Gwyneth
Paltrow played a pivotal role in
bringing down Harvey Weinstein yes well
Joe was quote determined to bring down
Harvey Weinstein and played a pivotal
role in doing so behind the scenes
according to the two journalists who
broke the bombshell story the actress
who started mine seemed produced
Shakespeare in Love was one of the first
in Hollywood to get in touch with New
York Times reporter megan Twomey and
jody canter quote i think that many
people will be surprised to discover
that when so many other actresses were
reluctant to get on the phone and scared
to tell the truth about what they had
experienced at his hands that Gwyneth
was actually one of the first people to
get on the phone and that she was
determined to help this investigation
talk to he said on The Today Show on
Monday to Eva called a time when
Weinstein showed up early to a party at
Paltrow's house in the Hamptons
prompting her to quote hide in the
bathroom and call Cantor in fear quote I
think Harvey Weinstein was extremely
aware and extremely scared of what the
implications would be if his biggest
star actually ended up going on the
record she said the episode plays out in
Cantor and to his new book she said
breaking the sexual harassment story
that helped ignite a movement
wait that's so crazy and like just gave
me chills that she's hiding in her
bathroom and this is just another reason
why we Stan went at Paltrow I've been
saying it for over a year
she is the modern woman and I [ __ ]
chip her and me I know and she really
gets such a bad rap I know and it's so
unwarranted no you know what it was like
during a time what I think that she was
just like you know going through like
a lot of self-discovery just like saying
things like conscious uncoupling that
like made people hate her and people
like never let go of that even though
she like is an amazing person
yeah it's not the conscious uncoupling
because or maybe I just heard her
explain it so now I understand it but
it's I think it's just a lot of like
what goop does that feels unrelatable
right like $600 facemasks right but like
will I look like Gwyneth Paltrow no but
like there's a market for that like good
on her for tapping into a business you
know yeah no but I feel like everyone is
so quick to forget like all of her
wonderful roles like all the good that
she's done you know she seems to be a
great mom like she's with Brad Falchuk
who's just a premium content creator so
like a cookie she's like how could the
creator of screen queens like not be
with a wonderful one Jackie you're just
founding [ __ ] facts right now like
the Brad Falchuk of it all the Glee of
it all the [ __ ] Country Strong of it
all that movie up in the air where her
and Kelly press center flight attendants
New Jersey and of course not Kelly
pressing Christina Applegate Kelly
presses into - but she didn't pass the
test in the very beginning so she gets
left behind in the small town really
Mike Meyers Yeah right where right like
she just has an index of films that are
so impressive
they don't get spoken about enough and I
think she's a wonderful person like I
happen to be in love with her so I think
that as a culture we need to seriously
take a step back on the hating runneth
Paltrow because we're wrong right and
like if she was a pivotal figure in
taking down her be mine scene whose
takedown was pivotal for the whole meet
you movement and she has a whole like
Thank You Quentin right I think why
people are saying it's such a big deal
is because like she was like what
Jennifer Lawrence is like Jennifer
Lawrence became the biggest movie star
in the world off of The Weinstein
Company films yeah and that's why people
were so disappointed when Jennifer
Lawrence never spoke up and never said
anything so sweet right but then like
when it's Paltrow who is very much
cemented in her family she didn't have
to do and do or say anything like she
lives her own life like in the Hamptons
in Malibu and she doesn't have to get
involved but she did because it was the
right thing to do and that's why it's so
impressive like we stand and we ship
yeah we really do justice for her next
story is actually really exciting and
something on anything expect to hear it
is here but here we are
Rihanna's new album is reportedly set
for a December release really mm-hmm
multiple reporters who were covering
Universal Music France open session
then and the label confirmed that the
anti singer will be releasing her ninth
studio album in December Rihanna has
stayed relatively quiet about her
upcoming collection but rumor has it
that it's a reggae album this is really
exciting and December is not too far
away Wow I can't believe how long it's
been since Auntie and honestly I've lost
interest I'm not gonna lie like I mean I
love Rihanna ship her love everything
savage I love everything fancy and like
I love everything Fenty beauty but like
at some point I just like lost momentum
and stopped really caring and now I care
more about Rihanna as a businesswoman
then a singer but I don't think you need
to like I don't think you need to care
right now like do what you're doing but
when that album drops like you'll be
there so it's a reggae album or in the
words everyone a singer or reggae I
don't know they didn't specify also he
was written so I don't know what that
end to say um but I'm hoping maybe cuz
it's in December it's a Christmas album
Christmas reggae album like Diana by
Rihanna that would be wonderful and he
was such a good album yeah I think we
say auntie weird is it anti yeah I think
you could say whatever you want but it's
yeah like I'm anti everything but yeah
but ha but you're the Antichrist that's
true
auntie is Prince different ways but when
I think rihanna made it as an album i
think it's when the word anti stands
alone its anti but when it's with
another word maybe it's an T or maybe
you just go through it quicker so you
just say auntie maybe maybe it's ng
Sneaky's maybe we should to get Rihanna
on the show and ask her her exact
opinions yeah but I do think it's anti
see me Jess I mean that may be her next
album yeah she's an auntie right like
she ever an inch of Kristen this weekend
at Bloomingdales with her aunt did you
say these are my auntie's oh my god and
some so now I'm thinking it's auntie ya
know auntie's are really a sunny Bunch
no and I'm truly I'm telling you like I
feel isn't a like there's been justice
for auntie's a vehicle posts definitely
like experimenting with yeah I think for
a long time Khloe Kardashian like took
that role on her back put the empty on
her back okay
felt like I was seeing some I was on
someone's Instagram or something and
they something was about like all the
auntie's like [ __ ] dead and when we
were all together Krisha bottom Friday
and CEO was literally with
his auntie's like I know he just felt
really good there's something to be said
about the lemon and Kristen Brown sent
auntie's either or auntie's auntie's
tomato tomahto
potato risotto I just think like and the
community is stronger than ever
yeah I really do it when I feel like
auntie's are stepping up to the plate
what happened right I told her and I
think nieces and nephew says nephews are
appreciating it I think they are I mean
specific to my situation you know I feel
like maybe that was a good time until
you know I feel like Theo told me
actually last night he's been feeling
like kind of let down by his auntie's
specifically you because did he I
haven't really shown any interest in
like coming to see well I haven't come
around because Theo lives in a swamp
okay Theo doesn't live in a swamp Theo
got a new toilet yesterday boo boo they
say it's the gold standard of toilets
and these floors are are almost there
like not close but almost I know but
like you would understand why we don't
hang out of Theo's when like we all have
apartments with floors that are there
yeah but your floors oh yeah that's true
but they should I just want to express
some disappointment from Theo I
understand don't shoot the most I
understand but it really and this
happens sometimes with auntie's nephew
situations where it's like the issue
it's actually at the top between the
auntie and the mother oh please blaming
me I'm leaning in for your floors it's
not the oh my god I feel like you know
when you have like a period that's like
so big like you can't have a wonder like
the back she got pregnant this one they
would have had triplets
yeah for sure oh my god my stomach's
[ __ ] killing me I'm so sorry that was
me I'm trying not to be weird but I got
my period last night like before bed
isn't weird uh I feel
what do you I've never not woken up with
my berry that's how I am too but I don't
know if everyone's like that
I just got it I feel like somebody just
get in like in the middle of the day
like the worst possible time oh that's
literally never happened to me I got it
right before bed I was so confused I'm
like I've been stabbed
yeah like maybe like your your body is
jet-lagged or something maybe or maybe a
week later and like you really just
would have woken up with it no it was
like eleven hmm interesting it was
really weird just some interesting
vaginal facts I wanted to share with my
friends here at the test thank you
okay next story really funny Caitlyn um
Kendall Jenner's ex Blake Griffin Roast
Caitlyn Jenner forgiving her daughter's
daddy issues oh my god wait I saw this
story but I didn't understand the the
connection that he used to date Kendall
right and they film the Roast of Alec
Baldwin which I'm actually looking
forward to right and I guess Caitlyn
Jenner was there and found herself the
butt of some jokes has people at roasts
do I find that like the people they
choose for celebrity roasts are so
random like me and Ben went to the Rob
Lowe roast and they had an Coulter there
and it was honestly horrifying yeah oh
the I mean but also the people they
choose to get roasted like it's usually
someone who wants to rehabilitate their
image Justin Bieber but like Rob Lowe
didn't eat I guess maybe it's just like
a fun thing yeah well I think that's
pretty smart
I feel so conflicted when it comes to
Alec Baldwin because like in my soul I
know that he is a like a nasty terrible
person like I know it with every fiber
of my being like he if he met me like he
would be mean to me look and I know that
but there's something about like just
the Jack Donaghy of it all and like so
much of his work
it's complicated like I [ __ ] love him
now you know how people feel about
Michael Jackson oh that's true but it's
like I can forgive you know Alec Baldwin
for like punching a paparazzi and
calling his daughter a pig like I just
have a harder time forgiving Michael
Schaff sanitation yeah and like the
details that they went into in the HBO
documentary which were absolutely vile
saying he's put was putting his tongue
and people's blood holes sorry that's
how they said in the documentary not me
not my words
HBO's totally okay well wear it like the
Dave Chappelle special says Michael
Jackson appreciated the long gander at
the [ __ ] yeah at the Amos Alec
Baldwin may have been the latest target
of the famed Comedy Central Rose honey I
also feel conflicted about roasts in
jail right because everyone is there to
roast one person but then the person
getting up to roast also roasts all the
other Roasters not even that but like
who could put themself through a roast
and now Deandra is doing it Emile has a
talent like literally Mary knows no
bounds did you have you seen Joan Rivers
documentary recently yes like in my
adult life yes so there's a point where
they're filming her and she gets asked
to do the Comedy Central Roast and it's
like it's literally the saddest part of
the documentary she's like it's so much
money and you know her she didn't turn
down a dollar and she was always working
and she needed money she was lived a
very extravagant life and she said she
was
really not looking forward to it like
the jokes calling her see what next did
next Tuesday making fun of her face like
and you could tell like that was the
thing that really got to her and it was
like a really sad part of the
documentary where like she does it
because she genuinely needs the money
and she needs the the platform but like
it's sickening for her like if she's
sitting there I would not be able to
handle it I feel like some people just
like take it in stride like you could
say anything I don't know I think I'm
like really sensitive oh my god no I
mean so I never tap in dude I mean
you're more sensitive than me I never
tap into like my horoscope because I
think honestly that entire thing is
[ __ ] like astrology but like cancers
are very known for like being bullies
who like can't take it you know and
that's literally me I'm so mean to
everyone
anybody Savannah Palma cancer probably
and if anyone that comes for me like I
will immediately cry and go home
interesting I wonder what the the
stigmas around Scorpios are I don't want
to get into it cause like I don't wanna
become one of those shows like I'm like
a camp I'm being such a Scorpio today
yeah yeah I gotta say to the anagram I
think that's me to at least like you
earn your way to the Erin and Graham
like for cars when we were just [ __ ]
born your and did all the work agreed
Alec Baldwin made been the latest target
of the themed Comedy Central Roast and
next obedient recent source just make a
dangerous trip the Caitlyn Jenner found
herself on the receiving end of some
sick burns made by none other than her
daughter Kendall Jenner's ex-boyfriend
threat Blake Griffin at the taping for
the upcoming special quote Caitlyn
completed her gender reassignment in
2017 finally confirming that no one in
that family wants a white dick the
Detroit Pistons power forward tees in an
NSFW sneak peak release diamond mmm-hmm
then he played curtain also made a joke
saying listen I know we're all here
making fun of Caitlyn but I want to take
this moment to publicly thank you as an
athlete I want to thank you for your
bravery as a human I want to thank you
for the doors you've opened and on
behalf of the entire NBA and half of the
rappers and the Billboard charts I want
to thank you for giving your daughters
their daddy issues really really funny
really Blake Griffin had jokes well
Blake Griffin I'm sorry anyone in it who
does the comedy roast who is not a
comedian has the writers right joking
him and that's why when I was at the
roast like Ann Coulter wouldn't let
anyone write jokes for her and she was
like being my paranoid she's being so
crazy
it was honestly the craziest a my life I
couldn't believe what I was watching
news dad Thailand and so awkward soap
like Griffin definitely had someone
write this for him like from the network
oh definitely but like it also takes you
know a comedic flair to the river I
totally agree so good for him
I wonder what really the impetus behind
Alec Baldwin doing this is I think it's
a rehabilitation thing behind you
percent like you definitely were Justin
Bieber which it really did yeah it will
work for Alec Baldwin and it made me
Billy Bush should do one too by the way
that's actually a great idea I just
don't think he's honestly relevant
enough no and like they have real like
[ __ ] movie stars doing it yeah no of
course but it just the interest humpin
they also don't do roasts very often no
the last one was Rob Lowe and I think it
was three years ago this
oh yeah well so well blow was like three
years ago yeah I so maybe it's a what
nothing what it's Pritchett I'd been to
a roast I've been to a rose yeah we're
talking about the roast sorry like I get
him ready to cool events yeah that is a
cool event Academy honestly it was and
that's when cat see David sin Pete
Davidson and Cassie David I was
confusing we're together um and I like
no Cassie and I was like really like
talking at her and Pete and like I've
never felt polar in my life that's
pretty cool it's pretty cool okay this
and then I'm gonna run to the Rob Lowe
Rose no okay actually when we were Kim
and Kourtney and I wear that metallic
silver bomber jacket that the last time
I wore that was a Rob Lowe roast with
actually your dress underneath it
they're like turtleneck yes and I'm some
over the knee boots and like a Chanel
necklace and I borrowed from mom and
like I was literally taking 1 million
pictures with it and I got my pictures
taken on the red carpet that's actually
the first red carpet I ever walked and
like overall like do you look back on
that look fondly I mean I just always
hard
I always up until I got my chin done
that was the moment I looked back on it
was like that was my look now since I
got my chin done then when I look back
on is the TPG Awards where I was like
[ __ ] snatch I don't know like what
happened to my body that day but like I
literally like come on over the
snatchler is that day yeah and so they
said we took actually a picture together
and we're not even touching I know so
snatched no I know and it's literally
like me location
my profile picture it's right it's a
grand picture like it's my background on
my phone is my LinkedIn picture like
it's literally everything so TVG Awards
are coming up again in December and like
I need to get back and snatch it into
like TPG Awards but I got a dress
already which is so unlike me being so
prepared yeah that is unlike you I'm
just wondering why you were trying on
dresses I thought you must have been
invited to another rose no I was just in
the store like looking for a clothing
and I saw the dress and you never know
and like you just need a dress and
anytime I need a dress I don't have one
so I figured now it's good to have like
my closet stocked with dresses that like
I might wear is that when you ran into
Kristin and her auntie's yes and it's
also when I got that single SEP sweater
that I wore last night like everyone was
complimenting me on I it was great but I
was so [ __ ] hot like literally the
feathers were so excited how was your
night it was good I went to Antony
book party at by the way outlet Avenue
at Saks have you been no we have to go
it's our spot like where I was looking
for spots
that's us money love a department store
a restaurant we'd love a department or a
restaurant and we love a department
store restaurant where the entire PR
teams made up of chaucer's who walks
into the party and the PR girl was like
can we get your photo I'm like all the
time and Anthony has booked so everyone
show got it oh and I ran into bread
Gretzky and you know what he said to me
is it Oh which makeup artists did your
eyeliner oh I was like excuse me and
then it's telling me all about the
gallery have you been seeing this drama
with the Gary no so probably you know
Brad is married to Gary yeah and Brad
again and he's been like doing this
really funny um like set of Instagram
stories where he just has been on
vacation with Gary and Gary I guess it's
like real foodie and he's very
particular he's a kind of snobbish and
he just films Gary every time I was at a
restaurant it's just really funny and
then Gary um was talking about his
Starbucks order it's like very specific
it's vegan and it takes a really long
time to make I know people like all
around the world or ordering Gary and
they're going into mean like I know Gary
and people except worse like I don't
know if that is and I said I'm like um
he's heard from Starbucks he's like
literally no they haven't even sent us a
gift card like nothing they just
followed me on Instagram
oh well honestly that was that worth
something yeah but they're not marrying
- no not at all but they really look
I've seen so many people ordering the
gary like on my Instagram really yeah
it's like a nationwide thing interesting
and it's vegan that's why cuz it's like
oat milk and some of the [ __ ] yeah
yeah well speaking of and that's
actually what they served at the comedy
Rose
[Laughter]
roast actually they it was like a full
seated dinner it was like a bar-mitzvah
how was this [ __ ] amazing and the
bread basket is all I really remember
well speaking of food and plant-based
meat grocery stores new dilemma where do
they sell this me Oh [ __ ] Rosen and
does it go with the meat oh so now this
is what Kroger is combating right now
and I just want to say personally like I
want it with the meats like it's just
less confusing and Kroger by the way I
don't know it's like a big deal I've
never been to a Kroger but because they
don't have them like anywhere on the
East Coast and they also owned by
Walmart it seemed like a lot of Kroger
Walmart drama crossover yeah I don't
have lab I doesn't think about I think
they might be people are eager to try
plant these meat alternatives Kroger
wants to make sure they'll know where to
find them honestly this is like
pertinent information people on a daily
[ __ ] basis know and it's right here
to do we've been working for years to
find like an alternative like
plant-based meat and now that we have it
like we can't figure out where to put it
we can find it and like those are always
the coldest aisles so like I just want
to know exactly where to get I agree the
grocery chain is trying out a dedicated
plant-based protein section in its meat
aisle 60 locations in parts of Indiana
and Illinois as well as in Denver we'll
run the tests for 20 weeks this fall
traditionally vegan and vegetarian items
have been sold far away from the meat
meat aisle but is more meat eaters try
plant-based alternatives the arrangement
could end up leaving some interested
shoppers out totally also like I want to
go to the burger section I don't care
what my burgers made up like don't send
me to some vegetarian reaction and also
like if these like brands like my of
like impossible burger are like really
branding themselves like you cannot
believe it's not me like then it should
be with me right and they're also
branding themselves it's like you don't
have to be like a quinoa kale eat to
enjoy an impossible burger like it's for
the burger lover so like don't send me
off with kale chip well how does it have
to be stored in frozen yeah I actually
just bought some beyond meat patties
from the grocery store for your house
for my house I haven't cooked them yet
it is exciting I'm scared I'm gonna like
watch it and I also kind of I was having
this conversation with Olivia and Zach
because we just have such intellectual
conversations where we talk about what
kinds of vegetarian burgers we'd like to
make in the home and I was saying I
I kind of like the idea of only eating
impossible foods when I go out I got a
special special thing it makes me feel
like I can have a burger when I'm home
like I can have doctor preggers or
Morningstar and lose my virginity yeah
not a big deal of losing my virginity at
home and those are like really easy to
eat and really easy to cook and I don't
want to like ruin impossible burgers for
myself by having them but yeah there was
like a weird period in my life when like
I just mean I have such weird eating
habits and like it makes it really hard
to like snack that like there was a
period in my life where like I would
make like a full-blown hamburger like
for meals and snacks like all the time
in my house it was so weird that is
really I just like take a patty grill it
up and they put it on a bun that's
delicious
it was weird Jada Newman makes an
interesting point about this grocery
store dilemma I feel like the quinoa
kale vegans will be triggered if they
have to go to the real meat section well
to be honest like their that's their
problem if you can be triggered by a
pack of meat like maybe the grocery
store isn't for you maybe but what about
this and I've thought about this before
like how come we can't have just some
impossible foods in the meat section and
some in the meegan section like it's
like sometimes there are things that
would work in two different sections you
know but then I think you're just
getting will also because shelf space is
expensive so if they're not from shark
tank so yeah if you're one product is
taking up what two products could take
up like you're losing money in a grocery
store because like there could be a
different bag of quinoa where that would
one impossible thing would be it just
doesn't make sense economically I think
damn okay that was like a good you know
like middle ground solution I'm just not
economically yeah I should have a
grocery store and when people please
there's like none of the shelves make
sense yeah you go in order of like
cravings well you know I find do you
find that when you're at a grocery store
which by the way a grocery stores are
some of my like favorite places in the
world my most cherished memories yeah
and it's like brick and mortars are
constantly being taken down and like I'm
here for it cuz honestly Amazon does
everything bigger and better but grocery
store shopping is one of the very few
like past times that I will miss when
they go out eventually go out of
business I don't think that they will I
mean they're going out of business all
around town oh I think in the city like
it's hard to go to grocery stores and
you don't have a car and who wants to
carry all that stuff home so like so
people really rely on like instacart
instacart totally but I think in the
suburbs like they're as prominent
prevalent oh good point and by the way I
just like lived for going grocery
shopping especially in the suburbs like
it's a whole other yes
you go shopping like I live near a
grocery store and I never go there
I don't live near any grocery store so I
use Peapod and I have it delivered yeah
I use all I've actually been dabbling
with a bunch of different grocery store
services really uh yeah just cuz
different needs you know for different
time different weeks yeah different
perfumes for different seasons we're
rolling into fall I think I'm gonna
change up to a more maple based product
just to get really like the fall vibes
out there and I can do that because I
subscribe December yeah and they have
definitely have an assortment of maple
based products right I think I can
actually search by maple base you can
you can search the price tag probably
but like I don't know if you'll get
maple no I hope not
Sanford is a luxury fragrance
subscription service for perfumes and
colognes it's a way for you to discover
new perfumes and colognes without buying
an entire bottle they have more than 450
designer brands for you to choose from
Tom Ford Prada verse ace tilt Josie and
gabay nning cartier glossy a wow they
really are keeping up with the brand's
I'm you could try the brands you want
it's the real deal you choose to perfume
you want to try they'll send you a
30-day supply that's 120 sprays enough
to apply more than four times daily for
a month then the next month you can
choose the same one get a new one try
something different if you're not sure
what type of st. you're looking for you
can sort and find your fragrance by
brand style occasion sees anymore that's
why with our exclusive offer for our
listeners you can get 50% off your first
month at scent bird comm slash toast
that's only seven dollars and fifty
cents for your first fragrance scen TBI
RDECOM slash toast for you to try your
first perfume or cologne for just $7.50
Sandberg comm slash toast 50% off your
first month sign on smell amazing
there's no excuse not to smell amazing
now that we thought you hooked up with
some bird it's actually such a good I
used my sin bird this weekend and like
for I literally forgot to pack like so
many important things for my one day
trip I forgot makeup remover
I forgot I shadow like though I'm a
wedding I don't [ __ ] know but I had
my scent bird thank God so I was
smelling I was signing on and I was
smelling amazing
that's the if you never party is signing
on mmm I know such a tough choice a
deandra's choice between Medici Vita
wheat was that left right below deck
half hazard lane okay I didn't watch
because I was getting like inundated
with DMS about your plots and like that
was just
interesting and now there are so many
movies like I want to see get made yeah
well that's what I was actually what
it's thinking about when I was at The
Comedy Central Roast was like all the
movies I wanted to get me and like all
the jokes that like you would have yeah
actually I was thinking that because you
know I think I can do anything better
than like everyone even like
professional comedians and the writers
well now you are professional comedians
yeah I really encourage everyone to
watch the Joan Rivers documentary before
they watch to the roast she actually
gives a lot of good behind-the-scenes
stuff like she they're practicing her
entry and they're like telling her what
you do she's like it'll be funny cuz I'm
funny it was just great moment for
everyone including me I'm glad you
enjoyed it also instacart like when they
go pick up your groceries they go to a
grocery store
so like pertinent I'm sorry what like
you're saying instacart is gonna put
like grocery stores out of business but
like good call yeah oh my god Doug
that's what we're saying so much below
tech have happened yeah it's good um I
don't know chef been like he's crazy
he's like a dick but like there's
something really endearing about him and
that's what everyone feels about him
everyone like really hates him but also
kind of likes him and you know what he
gets his job done that's literally all
that mad but it's also making me feel
like this boat that they're on like no
offense is a piece of [ __ ] it's
rinky-dink us but I'm like he keeps
talking about the kitchen how it's so
small he can't find anything and none of
the burners work and it's like is this
not like a side start kitchen in past
seasons that I've watched they always
have problems with like size of the
kitchen and like storage and looking for
stuff but I've never seen where like
actual appliances don't work and that's
where it's like I think you draw the
line yeah but it does at the end of the
day it's not gonna be like a chef's
kitchen it's tiny and all the staff
quarters on boats like that are tiny
right but like a flashback to some of
the other kitchens they were bigger Oh
were they yeah and also like Hannah was
saying like use the oven you know stop
making dishes like you could change what
you're gonna make for the next meal
right something that would require an
oven but I think like chefs more often
than not like use pans and like on this
I think use a stove improvised yeah and
stop relying so much on the stove yeah
but it's [ __ ] annoying oh for sure
and it's annoying to watch - yeah I
don't know I feel like the seasons
minding now and everyone's like getting
sick of each other and that's when it
gets good yeah but it's like I'm kind of
like feeling for them in their cabin
fever I'm like oh I don't want to find
them like I don't want to let this slide
up even when they start talking about
like cabin fever and just like the
quarters
it actually really reminds me of camp a
lot like when you're in camp and you're
like living in the same bunk with the
same people for two months if you really
start to get over it very quickly ya
know it happens like with every reality
so I feel like it's happening with
paradise I'm actually excited to watch I
finished a wonderful homework movie last
night that a beach house the beach house
I was talking about it yesterday I
finished it um the plot of the movie is
actually the exact plot of the last song
but with different actors and who are a
little bit older so I really do
recommend it you know it was a great
plot one so why not do it again
I agree just something to think about
and not played you once don't make me
slay you again he Davidson's
girlfriend's mom is in it and she was
tell he's a wonderful actress
I should take classes from her but she's
so Hallmark she really is I need to meet
her I feel like I'm always being me like
older women in Hollywood yeah that's
like my thing
the old woman whisperer yeah and he said
I need to yes by the way I finally
understand that username Justin
literally as the lady said he's like the
babysitter for ladies for ladies like
rich fancy cool fun ladies no totally oh
my god I watched his just the sip with
Jason Wahler from the hills I can't even
tell you Justin Bobby no Jason Wahler
watch I don't know
remember LC didn't go to Paris but
because yeah he's on the hills with his
wife now and by the way they're actually
I know I said Mesa Bartman's my favorite
but like they are like the heart and
soul Oh got it hills new beginnings and
they are exactly like the best case
scenario for like people turning out
well after the show that's good he was
an addict and like struggled with
getting sober for a long time and his
wife is a [ __ ] precious gem of a
woman's and stands by him like he now
does all this work like for fellow
addicts and like oh they're just such a
wonderful couple and like he's still
like it's still a struggle every day and
like he did his interview with Justin
justice if you guys shouldn't watch it
because they messaged us and it was
amazing oh but also it's does he drink
alcohol no oh so justice if Justin Sarah
serves a oh well he obviously did it and
they were just talking about like all
different forms of addiction and like
male body image issues and it was just
so good it was such a great interview
and like justin is such a pro justin is
such a good interviewer look I love him
I love your episode of Jesse also media
available on YouTube yeah no it was
premium so just thought I'd shout it out
okay if there's nothing else you didn't
watch falling in love
I didn't yesterday we just happened to
be such a busy day and today it's gonna
be so busy - like I'm meetings 12:30 2
o'clock 4 o'clock like oh my god and
then 4 o'clock now 4:30 just say now oh
thank you and then I also have a
birthday party tonight so I'm gonna try
I also have to watch paradise like I so
falling in love is on my back burner but
we're watching um just a friend like a
close personal friend just a better
later okay home and doing nails
how was that um not a success it's
definitely like a practice like makes
perfect sort of thing well I didn't want
to like call you out yesterday but I was
like shocked that you had no nail polish
like I've never seen you without it now
I just really been not in the mood to
those things get a manicure and I just I
post there waves like that to where it's
like I just I would rather die then good
then go to the manicure place but I've
been living for my manicure place these
days like I start I make it in Oasis i
buy i buy fresh and koh samet telling us
and I get a backrub and I make Margo
come with me like you make it a fun
little day I know but it's like you know
what else it was a fun day staying home
since that's something to think about
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the Millennial morning
show we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so
feel free to subscribe to us on YouTube
which is youtube.com slash morning toast
we're also doing a new thing where we
name our episodes so if you how we have
our name suggestions let us know that'll
be really fun and we're also available
as a podcast if you can't watch live
we're available on iTunes Spotify
stitcher anywhere you can listen to
podcasts to subscribe over there leave
if I start of you but how beautiful and
smart we are and that's all we got on
Claudia Austrade tickets available to my
toward the jodyjean store at girls no
job calm I'm meeting of us in this
Friday and then in the following months
I'm going all over the West Coast
Seattle Vancouver San Diego San
Francisco Los Angeles
Toronto just a bunch of places so
tickets available Carlton chop calm
have a great day see em
you